foreign
Billiards competitive Billiards is that
men's and women's Billiards or do men
and women compete on the same playing
field in Billiards I do not know the
answer to that my guess would be same
same playing field but I don't know yeah
that would be my guess too but I'm not
100 sure exactly it's not even 60 sure
of that uh Billiards competitions male
versus female something like that
um and I also want to add a an odd
exception maybe it's one of several but
American football
right there is no women's American
football right
um there's men's and women's soccer
interestingly I would guess rugby is
like football and that there's no
women's rugby no no there's
college level women's rugby I think but
anyway it is interesting that well and
then you have uh baseball and softball
right like women's baseball I mean
certainly some women play baseball
sometimes but I don't think that there's
professional women's baseball
um if you're playing that kind of a game
as a woman professionally you're playing
softball and Men also play softball
right but women don't also play baseball
I think right now I can't I don't think
I ever saw A League of Their Own but am
I right that women were playing baseball
during the War I thought it was softball
but I remember well in any case there's
an interesting landscape here why don't
we have women's football uh why you know
why is the logic of soccer not the same
logic as American football
um there's a question about whether or
not
so
if men play at a higher level in uh
sports that are physically that physical
prowesses the question
um then it's interesting that women's
sports work and I want to point out why
I think they do but
if you what do you mean what they work
what does work mean if
the top men
are
if no woman can compete with the top men
in a sport like let's say tennis
then the question is why if people are
going to see the top tennis players does
women's tennis make sense and the answer
so you're talking about as a spectator
sport not as a sport as a sport there's
I don't know right right question right
no I I am talking I'm talking about the
spectations yes I'm talking about why it
makes sense that we have you know amends
and women's division at Wimbledon for
example
um and I think the answer is not a word
incidentally what that's the word I used
expectation expectations I like it
um well you can be very persuacious so
um precisely yeah the so I guess my
point would be one of the things about
you know what is a sport
a sport is a a physical game in which
the obstacles faced by the competing
parties are the same right so they you
know you can't play soccer on a slanted
field
um or if you do then the point is each
side spends if you play soccer in a
v-shaped field in which the goals are at
the end
you know yeah a little bit like ulama
the uh the Central American ball game
but oh yeah yeah with the slanted size
but anyway put that aside for a second
the game neutralizes now extinct
um like Aztec I think or Toltec or
something I believe it was actually
passed down the Olmec the Toltec the
Aztecs all played ulama and ulama still
exists it's just such a hard game that
it's not when it's played now though it
doesn't end in human sacrifice or no not
of either the winners or the losers
which I understand different cultures
did it differently yeah but this is a
game in which uh there's a tiny little
hoop like a basketball hoop but it's up
on edge and the ball I think can only be
uh passed around and launched with the
hip
it's a very crazy game but um
but anyway point is top women competing
with each other is not inherently a much
worse game than the top men pitted
against each other because they're even
with each other and and so anyway the
point interested in physical skill and
prowess if you're only interested in you
know speed and force yeah then uh the
the women's sport is not going to give
you as much of that as watching men's
sport
um but in general sport is not just
about
um you know sheer you know speed and
force right it's about skill and and
frankly and this is you know as I am as
I have said before back when we were
playing a lot of ultimate I played um I
played on the University of Michigan
Women's team uh for for a bit and then
we played a lot of summer summer league
you know captained co-ed teams and
um and also went to some you know
day-long tournaments and such and
watched
um and so watched a lot of men's games
played in a certain number of women's
games and played way way way more
co-ed games and and and and Captain
co-ed teams and by far for me you know
obviously I never played on a men's
men's game but by far the most
interesting of those was was the co-ed
games
um because men left their own devices on
the field were much more likely to just
like hook it long one guy runs down you
know maybe he gets to lay out and and
you know it's it's awesome for those two
guys and it's pretty great for the other
you know depending if it's a full you
know thing the other five people five
it's been a while seven yeah right seven
people don't recall oh goodness it's
been that long yeah um
the other people on the team but the
points are short and
um it's you know to you know to the
Victor go the spoil sort of thing and
um by contrast the women the women's
only uh games are much more likely to
involve very short passes much more
cautious less risky short passes it
takes forever to go down the field
um the person who does want to hook it
long or run and run and you know dive
into the end zone is much less likely to
have the opportunity and uh and there's
also more much more of a focus and this
will come as a surprise to No One
probably in our audience even if you
have no idea what ultimate frisbee is uh
is that on women's only in women's only
games and on women's only teams there's
much more of a focus on like let's make
sure everyone gets to handle the disc
like and let's let's make sure that
everyone ends up getting to play and
like actually this is competition here
that's that's not supposed to be one of
the main things and so you have these
like you know these slightly too much
like almost caricatures of maleness and
femaleness in an all-male Game of
Ultimate and all female game ultimate
and because this is not supposed to be a
contact sport uh and it really does work
as a co-ed in a co-ed game and usually
you know five two five men two women
four men three women something like that
and you got to be you know matched up
pretty well
um you actually reduce some of the
silliness of the extreme all male and
all female exigency is when you're
playing together right and it's
fantastic but it is neutralized
structurally as part of the game
ultimate is a strange game because it
actually builds into the structure of
the game uh inclusiveness and fairness
they're like the game actually has the
rules written in that somebody doesn't
understand a rule place stops and the
rules explain and all that so anyway the
point is structurally
in Ultimate right you wouldn't pick
teams and have an uneven number uh you
wouldn't have you know the preponderance
of of women on one team uh that would be
an unfair game there is a tendency to
balance the number of women on each side
and there is a tendency for players not
necessarily by sex but players to match
up with a player of similar skill and
speed so that one person is not fully
shutting down the other person so the
point is the game and if you don't have
that then you do a different kind of
Defense you don't do a man on defense
you do his own defense or something
right if you don't really have roughly
you know this is more in a non you know
strictly competitive situation right uh
like okay are we are we out here are we
doing pickup to have fun or to brutalize
the other team and the other team we're
going to swap it up in 15 minutes and
some of you people who I was just trying
to brutalize are going to be on my team
like yes I'm on a team right now and I
want to win this point because that's
fun and that's kind of why I'm out here
but I'm also not interested in like oh
let's line up with you who I know I can
take an outrun and then the point's
going to be over really fast yeah it's
not interesting not interesting yeah
um so
well anyway look I think I think the the
really interesting one here is the
acting one and your question is a great
one about why the acting before we go
back to acting though because I actually
um you kind of predicted one of the
other places I wanted to go and maybe
we'll end on acting I actually found um
in the Seattle Times uh a couple weeks
ago January 22nd there's an article
called uh headlined renowned Hawaii surf
contest the Eddie plans return after
seven years and I don't I don't surf
um I've I've never watched a surfing
contest I don't know very much about it
despite having grown up in Los Angeles
um but one of the things that they say
in here in this article and I have
failed to Mark where it is is that for
the first time I believe
um ever they're inviting women to
compete
so this is this is not going to be the
Eddie and maybe this has already
happened at this point I think this has
been long enough
um uh for the first time it's not going
to be just a male only competition and I
thought okay
so we have as the reasons that I had
come up with for why there need to be
categories by under what conditions
there should be categories by sex
um in those situations where men and
women are just fundamentally different
enough that
um combining
um you know combining the sex categories
would mean that women wouldn't get to
play basically
um there is the historical reason for
like oh we're going to write some wrong
and so make sure that uh you know women
get
um get get voice here and then there's
um
this is about human versus nature and so
I you know I looked into how it is a
surfing contests are judged and it's a
little it's a little figure skating-y
right so there's a lot like it's judges
on the top and the bottom scores are
mostly dropped and I'm sure it's
different and different in in different
competitions but
um they're assessing on a number of
things like how many Maneuvers they use
and and you know and how you know
obviously if they
if they wipe out that's that's not good
um but there are measures of like you
know apparent power apparent strength
apparent fluidity on on the wave which
is going to give an advantage to to male
Surfers but if a competition is on a
particular day at a particular break and
apologies I'm probably not using exactly
the right words here but you know there
will be different waves that happen at
10 A.M versus 2 p.m of course but if
it's your turn to go out part of what
you're being assessed on is like which
wave did you choose and the waves are
the waves uh then it's you know it's
human against nature which is
um remarkable and in this case like well
um you know men may have a little bit of
an advantage but really like what are
you going to do if you're going to make
if you're going to call surfing a sport
and this gets back to the question like
what is a sport if you're going to call
surfing a sport just like if you're
going to call figure skating a sport
you're going to have to introduce some
social means by which you're assessing
whereas if it's a you know it's ulama in
mesoamerica or Ultimate Frisbee or
American football or you know what
everyone else calls footballers the
world soccer where there are you know
formal rules it's you know there is you
know there there are there are
dimensions and specificities around the
court or you know or the field and the
size or shape and density of the ball or
the disc or whatever it is uh and how it
is that you score and what the
conditions are then uh you can control
everything and it's it's a little bit
like human versus nature but controlled
it's like we've domesticated yeah it's a
domesticated War at some level and then
like okay now let's now let's play at
this it's a laboratory sport in the
sense that the laboratory purges all of
the extraneous uh influences as much as
possible so that you can see the effect
in a tennis court is similar to this
whereas you know it's like the
difference between
um uh gymnastics in the Olympic sense
and parkour which makes use of exactly
things that are non-standard
um but I did want to uh you want to go
back to acting well before that I wanted
to point out that
there are two reasons there are two male
female asymmetries that could result in
the need for a female category in sport
one of them might have to do with the
fact that males have an advantage
because the sport depends on strength
and things like that and my guess would
be this is somewhat relevant to
um surfing but you know there's a
question about if you scaled the board
down so that it was the same ratio of
person to board
maybe it's not on the other hand I don't
know
um on the other hand
to the extent that something is highly
competitive
it might be that if you didn't have
separate uh male and female categories
and you were looking at elite players
that women would not get there because a
much smaller pool of them would ever
have tried the sport and so the point is
the tales of the distribution that show
up would be much smaller and so the
number of people who would be able to do
it at an elite level having nothing
inherent to do with their capacity just
having to do with the fact that the
competitive modality would tend to
census more widely amongst men well as
you know I don't I don't buy this line
that is very common in the psychological
and other literature that women artists
competitive as men I think it's I think
it's total crap yeah but I'm not but men
and women compete differently it
manifests differently so if you're
reading something into my point it's not
there because my point is in the
athletic modality you would have had
fewer women attempt
this and so we'd find we wouldn't find
that many who had that Elite capacity so
I agree with you yes women are equally
competitive and it's different but the
sporting modality leans in the direction
of men
yeah I I think it would depend on depend
on the sport um but that's interesting
it's a different selection
bias it's a it's a selection bias about
choice in advance uh and this you know
this is related to some of the
some of the correctives that people are
trying to put into place not in sport
but in things like you know equity in
you know software Engineers you know the
sex ratio of software Engineers uh
whereas once you know Equity has been
achieved and actually like flown past
and now you have more women in say
medical school than men apparently I saw
I saw I saw this recently
um
no one no one is saying oh wait like
maybe we should then maybe we should
slow this down if what we're seeking if
what we were seeking was equity which is
to say uh you know and I don't I don't
think we should be but if what we were
seeking was that then it's supposed to
match the sex ratio of the population
then we got a problem we do have a
problem we got you know we got too many
other institutions favoring
um sort of female style of learning and
and making their way through the world
such that increasingly
um a lot of really really great manner
like not for me this doesn't this is not
doing anything for my brain I'm not
going to be able to manifest myself here
so I'm going to go do something else and
you know that's that's bad news and we
don't see we don't see that very much
being recognized we don't it's arguable
that it's correcting uh you know a
long-standing wrong and that's why they
don't respond I think it's nonsense but
uh but it's possible
foreign
[Music]